I hear that you gave my producers a
request I did want to host your show for
just a minute well we got a switch
tonight's alright okay okay this is
lower I feel like it's lower anyway okay
Kelly yeah you so much for being here
because I love you know it's you so much
Julie it's very I'm a huge fan as an
honor kiddo
so I have to ask you I am exhausted
doing one podcast interview you know a
week so you do this show every day well
my show every day and what is your
secret I was just asked this and I feel
like it was around my mom cuz my mom and
it's saying you've always been like this
like in high school I had like four jobs
and I was always doing stuff like at
school like student counselor and you
know a musical or something and Dante's
crazy definitely definitely
once a rambunctious home that one
favorite musical I did bitty but I I'd
say my favorite was probably seven
bright Seven Brothers
I love playing Millie you know what it
was this is actually interesting I've
never told him any this good job
interviewing um I I was doing summer
breads for some brothers what it was one
night and it was double cast that year
and that had never happened in our time
and to the other cast got all the shows
we got like one I know anyway but if we
worked so hard but we got to that one
song one man and it was actually the
first time cuz I grew up seeing opera it
was the first time I found like my chest
voice my gut like and really started
belting out and it was like such a
freeing boy what's the difference though
um it was like basically a sister act
you know when she does the thing with
the stomach oh happy day so it yeah it's
just using oh it's yeah and it was just
kind of switching gears for me from
doing opera you have to be so perfect
you have to be it became less about
perfection and technique and more about
passion and it was a really really
awesome moment for me I felt like I was
flying on stage I've never told that
story in my whole life Wow
[Applause]
well does that sign are you looking for
a co-host patient yes I am and I still
want to hear you sing it but we can do
that later I know I can't remember it
okay 37 we'll work on this yes let's do
it let's do it
I just love that I look like dr. evil
holding like a you know it's but he's on
my team I just talked about I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this